>> T Y
ITNG ME HE WOD USE TRDI WANT TO
VOTINGANAGER IN
GEORGIA.
I AOP THE WSRTNOTE, YOU HAPPEN
MAKE IT KNOWN Y VOTE IOTFF TOU .
XACT THI.
'SEIT, SENAT
LO PEUE
ASKING FOR GE
RESIGNATION,UT HAVING
THEOU WAY.M GOINGSAY
UNUN W  YOU HAVE
THE MOST SECURE IN
20 YEARS.
I THINK'S RIGHT.E IS SECURE.
U .
U W.TION YOU'S PAPER BLO REST OI
RIHENG TD W PLAY MORE OF WHATTO
RA >> I HAVE HARD TORID OFSIND D
EV NASTY,LEL,OOK TO DO IT.
YEAH,T IS PURE.
GE F OF
IT.
RIFEH VOTER F>> YOU LISTEN UP,
YORE T
TE CHINA.
>> YOUR REACTION,'VHA TOLD ME T
MENTIONED MEYINSANITY
BELROM ANYREALITY,ACD I'M
REPUBLICAN, AND I'M GOING TO
STAY A REPUBLICAN.
I'M GOING FIGHTOR
SANCTITY AND SYF A
AMERICA, AND
FIGH F I WAS 15
YEARS OLD, AND LYNN WOOD, THE O
VO A RUBY
SINCE 2004.IUE
D.AGING ANYBODY NOT TO VOTE
RIDICULOUS.
I CAN'T EVEN --ERIN,
I'TEN WHEREIS IBLE TO ME  PRESIS
THIS POINT HE'S LOST, AS YOU POT
IN AND
OUR HAND DEAD SPOT  THOUSANDOIND
RECOUNT, WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
DEAD COUNT  AND ANOTHER PAR
OF IS
WISCON WHE DOMINIOWORKED, PRESE,
WHEWE USED, OF THE
VOTE.
NONES WITH THE FLIMSIESTOF JUST
WHO BELIEVE IT.
KRES OUT THERE
WHO AREOI TEN
RAFF ENEMYF EAD ON TO HIS PROPE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT S
OFFTEWAKNOW, I
STEPPED UP TO A'M ON
I HAVE POLICE PROTECTIO HOUSE.
SECRETARY RAN FOR OFFICE.
AT SOME LEVEL IT COMES WY.
TERRUE
YE FOUND OUT 20 SOMETHIWAS LITE
JOB, AND HE WASGULAR PROCESS OFO
ANOTHER COMPUTER THESE QANON CR
MANIPULA
THEY FOUND HIS
IT WAS NAMEYED HIR WN, THERE WA
THAT SAID YOUKNOW, MAY GOD HAV O
YOUR SOUL AND HAD A
NOOSE, ANDOINT,E.
SO AND IT'S THIS
DISIND SAL INHA TAKEN
FR YOU.
HING ABOUT IT.THE REALITY IS HE.
HE'S NOT G TO
RHTTS, WE DOING.
THEY'RE FNEVUE.
THIS  JUST
SHOW UNNEAR AEROUS.
>> ANDOU, SO YOUE I THTAID SFUL
SECRETARY OFTENOFI RESPONSE T T
STUNNING?>> I SPO ONEAVENNT, BUG
TH
BUT THE  IS IF YOU WATCHRESIDE
TRUMP OK TWH DO.
HE VIEWS EVERYTHING VERYSACTION
D HEHE TO B DOWN
THIS IS WHAT COW , AND
THERE IS TIMES THAT'S THE
CORRECT POSITION TO TAKE, LET'S
SAY YOU'R F WITH CHINA SOMETHINN
THE END OF THE DAY, AND YES, YO
DUND
OUTCOMES IF YOU SEE LIT
THINGST T EDTEHE
ESPECIALLY WITH  ANOTHEROR T US.
AND THABECA
I KN I
MIRECIATE